yeah the balance is something that's
universal throughout all the 29 cities
of November yeah we jump up and down and
we yell like crazy people and then
you're hyped and then all is done you're
just ready to go run and conquer the
world
November project is free we utilize the
cities that we live in - what makes us a
little bit different from everywhere
else is that we put community first and
then the work out probably the best
reason to get up in the morning right
there is never of a project we started
just with grassroots and social media
Facebook Instagram Twitter is basically
all we've ever used for marketing big
circle everyone talked about like the
big sense of FOMO fear of missing out so
you see all these amazing photos online
you don't want to miss anything that
happens
we call them verbals and if you say
you're gonna be there you're you got to
be there usually you know you do up
available the night before and if you
don't show up you know everybody's gonna
be pretty mean we miss you is a message
that people post blaming the people who
dropped available and get and show up to
a workout if my friend does not show up
I'm going to tear you apart
on social media I'm something to admit
to you dear friend when you verbal 4np
last night I was slightly disappointed
our workouts are incredibly fun
high-energy and very competitive and
well you're just kind of mediocre out
after officially verbling online for
Friday Hills
Amy decides to unball which is not a
real thing she made that up
get that extra sleep rest knowing that
the tribe is doing wonderfully without
you there and that showing up would most
definitely dimmer if not completely kill
the vibe dear Polly and Jenna why see
we're both staying dry and getting your
extra beauty sleep yesterday we ate
Hills for breakfast I doubt your dog
would ever miss a workout or break a
verbal especially on her SF friends
because she is a loyal mother I don't
draw babbles it's a it's a it's a it's
safer when you join a gym your
accountability is that I put $50 a month
into this but here your accountability
is that I've committed to a friend and
he's a great time when you come out
there as well no gym can replace this
right so that's that's really what we
get out of it is motivation to be able
to get out there outdoors workout run
around very beginning of the day with a
bunch of other people that are just as
motivated
if you show up you're like oh I don't
know if I want to do this then by the by
the end of workout you're like yeah I'm
so glad I came